the lewis electron dot diagram for c2h4
is shown below in the box on the left in
the box on the right complete the lewis
electron dot diagram for
c2h5oh or ethanol by drawing in all of
the electron pairs so as i said this
right over here this is the lewis
electron dot diagram for ethene and they
want us to fill in all of the by draw
they want us to draw in all the electron
pairs for ethanol
and what we could do and i'll do it in a
way where we can see which electron
comes from which atom but they're not
even asking you to do that but in blue
i'm going to make the electrons from the
hydrogens so each hydrogen you can think
of it as contributing one electron to
each pair and that's what's forming the
covalent bonds so say this hydrogen is
going to contribute this electron
this hydrogen can contribute this
electron
this hydrogen can contribute this
electron
this hydrogen can contribute that
electron this hydrogen can contribute
that electron this hydrogen can
contribute
this
this electron
right over there
and then let's see so now let's think
about the carbons and if you were
actually taking the ap test you wouldn't
probably don't even have markers around
but i'm going to do it in different
colors just you can see it so each
carbon has four valence electrons that
it can contribute for these for covalent
bonding so this carbon right over here
that's one
two
three
and then
four
and now this carbon over here can
contribute one
two three
and
four
and now we think about the oxygen
so oxygen is interesting it's going to
have two lone pairs so it's going to
have one lone pair i could do there one
lone pair
like that and then it's going to have is
going to form this bond by contributing
one electron to this pair and one
electron to this pair right over there
so each of these pairs represent a
covalent bond this one i could have
drawn a little bit lower but i think you
get the idea those i have drawn in
all of the electron pairs
now let's think about part e what is the
approximate value of the carbon oxygen
hydrogen bond angle in the ethanol
molecule
so the ethanol they're really saying so
the ethanol molecule
they want to know the bond angle you
have the oxygen
bonded to a hydrogen
bonded to
the
c2h5
so i'll just write that as
c2 i'll just write c2
h5
like that and they want to know what is
approximately this bond angle going to
be
and the important thing to realize is
when you form these bonds with oxygen
it's going to have pretty close to a
tetrahedral shape why because the oxygen
has these two lone pairs
so these two lone pairs are forming the
other parts
the other
the other i guess you could say points
of the the tetrahedral shape and so if
we were talking about just water
so
water if we're talking about a water
molecule
right over here and i'm not doing a good
job of drawing it you could draw one
electron pair there and then the other
electron pair would be here in the back
actually i could let me draw it like
this
let me draw
i could draw it like this i could if we
were talking about water i could draw
one
hydrogen popping out
i could draw the other hydrogen
popping in and then one electron
pair is over here and one electron pair
is over here this bond angle over here
in water and this is i guess a
semi-useful thing to know in general you
could try to eyeball and say oh that
looks a little bit more than 100 degrees
and you'd be right this is approximately
100.5
degrees if you and this is actually not
a perfect tetrahedral shape it gets
distorted because these lone pairs of
electrons are
repelling each other and making these
two get in a little bit closer together
with each other if you have a pure
tetrahedral shape so you have something
in the middle
well let me just if you had a pure
tetrahedral shape like this
so let me
so let me draw it like this so something
popping out
you have something
something going in and then you have two
things like this
that's one way to think about a
tetrahedron there's others then the bond
angle between all of these if it's a
more i guess you could say symmetric
tetra a non a non-distorted tetrahedral
shape is
109.5 degrees and this is a reasonable
a reasonably useful number to know
obviously for this question as well i
don't know if you can if this is obvious
let me actually draw the tetrahede let
me let me connect the tetrahedron
so
you could draw it like
that and then that would be the other
side right there i don't know if that
helps let me draw another one
so
if i were to draw a tetrahedron and if
this was transparent you have a molecule
or you have an atom in the middle and
then you have the four bonds
one
two
three four i could say four bonds or
lone pairs then let me make sure you can
see the one in the center
then the angle here is approximately
109.5 degrees
so this is going to be tetrahedral but
you have these lone pairs that are going
to be
repelling each other a little bit so
you're going to be someplace in in the
neighborhood of i don't know around
where water is or a more pure
tetrahedral shape so i would say your
bond angle is going to be
i don't know between 104 and 110 degrees
104 to
110 degrees in fact i would i would
estimate that it's going to be more than
104.5 because
these the the well i'll just i won't
i won't try to dig too much into it they
really just want us to approximate
approximate the value so you could give
a
you know anything in this range would be
would be a a suitable suitable answer